[Music]
now earlier this month you'll remember
eight news now revealed our remarkable
woman that's right and now polita
Simpson wants to show you why her
students are remarkable as well so she's
the owner of positively or it's a local
organization that gives our youth a
space to use performance art as a vessel
of Hope well this weekend her students
are performing an original musical it's
called the Callback they would love for
you to attend tickets are ten dollars
for students 20 for general admission
VIP 35 bucks you can buy tickets on
positivelyarts.org of course it all goes
back to them yeah really incredible